Parag: That world of political
geography is not going away.
But, at the same time
we are engaging in this
topographical engineering.
These very robust engineering
systems by which
we modify the planet to
suit what we want it to do
what our various economic and
political activities are.
This is a very different
way of thinking about
how we map and what we map and
what matters most on the map.
( audience applause )
Connecto-graphy, connect-ography
I've already heard it pronounced
a thousand which ways.
But of course, what
I'm talking about
is the fusion of connectivity
and of geography
And all of that "connectivity
revolution", as I call it
falls into three
particular categories
that I liken to three
systems in the human body.
And what we have here is the
world's highways and railways
oil and gas pipelines,
electricity grids
internet cables.
All of this infrastructure that
has massively, exponentially
accelerated our ability to move
people and goods and resources
and knowledge and technology
and ideas around the world.
And that revolution is in, by
many measurements or metrics
really just getting underway.
As I said,
we are just in the early phases
of this incredible build-out
of global infrastructure.
By some estimates
we'll spend, not just the
$4 trillion per year
on infrastructure
that we spend today
but, rising to $7-8 trillion
in the coming years.
Meanwhile,
military spending worldwide
though it's rising in
quite a few geographies
as an aggregate, is
relatively steady
at around $2 trillion.
So, what happens
when we build-out
all of this infrastructure
as this... as these
infrastructures
sort of envelop and
wrap around the world?
I believe that we...
we evolve beyond one
of the most
ancient adages and phrases
that we all know.
Geography is destiny.
Instead, we think of
the arc of history
as really taking us in
a certain direction.
And that direction is more and
more and more connectivity.
There's a term in this
for academia.
Extra-statecraft, in which
that infrastructure is so real
where so many borders are
considered artificial
that it has an authority,
a gravity if you will.
And when countries
build infrastructure
like a highway or a railway
or an electricity grid
something really basic
you know, that they
share with each other
it winds up being something
that is almost a...
irrevocable bond.
It's obviously positive sum.
And the more of
those that you have
the less one thinks about
not sovereignty as guiding
their relations
but this connectivity
really shaping
how they relate to each other.
And so, that's the shift
that's happening now
from political geography being
the most paramount
feature of the map
which is again the borders
to the functional geography
which is the infrastructures
and the supply chains.
Gradually, what I believe
what happens next
is what I call the
"Global Network Civilization"
that eventually emerges from
all of this infrastructure.
Within that, you still have
empires, you still have nations
you have city-states, you have
all of these various actors.
But, it all adds up to a sort of
co-existing civilization.
The Sijori growth triangle.
Singapore,
Malaysia and Indonesia
are trying to
optimize their space.
And what you have here is
a case, where you have
a country Singapore,
which has very--
almost no land,
but a lot of capital.
Country like Malaysia
that has quite a bit of land
and labor and some capital.
And Indonesia, which has a lot
of land and a lot of labor
and very little capital.
So, you take these
three countries
that are all very close to
each other and they said
starting in the 1970s,
in the 1980s
"Let's start to take
Singaporean money
and Malaysian and
Indonesian land
and Indonesian labor and
put it on some islands
that nominally
belong to Indonesia
and let's start building ships
that are owned by
Singaporean companies.
But, let's optimize
our geography
let's treat it like we are
connected by one supply chain."
And that's what
they started to do.
And you wouldn't
know that there is
one set of rules in
one place and another
because now people can
increasingly move
seamlessly around them.
And that's how places one
by one, gradually...
neighbors shift, transition
from political geography
to functional geography.
But, the supply
chains are in fact
the original worldwide webs.
And they are,
that system of transactions
that gets any one thing to--
one thing from one place
to any another place.
And in many cases in the
global supply chain today
we no longer really know
where something is made.
And so, I believe that
the labels on everything
from clothing to computers
and so on
should really be
made everywhere.
If you look at where
the design is done
the manufacturing is done
the production, the
marketing, the distribution
the insurance,
the repair of any given product.
It involves companies and
sub-contractors and so forth
from all over the world.
There's very little that is made
exactly where the label
says it is, in fact.
And that's what happens when we
get to the supply chain world.
You can see it in the fact
that trade now reaches every
corner of the planet.
You can see it in
the ways in which
people in the financial
industry are affected
by the financial crisis of 2008.
Collapse of manufacturing as a
result of the financial crisis.
Automobile workers and
manufacturing workers
around the world
simultaneously lose their jobs.
You may not have noticed it
because that may not
be your circuit.
But, people who work in that
industry all over the world
simultaneously affected.
Such is the nature of that
connectivity among this project.
It is a very human thing
because each and every one of us
belongs to some kind of circuit.
And we move, we gravitate
towards the supply chain
towards these circuits.
We want to be part of them
and when the supply chain
and when infrastructure doesn't
come to you, you go to it.
Right, and that is why
so many people today
that's why there's more migrants
than ever in history today.
People are on the move.
One of the ways in which
economists or others
would measure the extent of
globalization is, they would say
"Well, X and Y
number of people
have crossed borders
any given year."
That's not the correct way
to measure
a globalization in my view.
It's how many people are
connected and to get connected
you don't have to move across
an international boundary.
Most people will never leave
the country they were born in.
But, if you move to a city,
you have access to services.
You may work in a factory
of a foreign company
you're connected
to supply chains
you'll have a mobile phone.
All of these things
connect you to the world
even though you have never
left the country.
So, to me,
the rate of urbanization
is the greatest measurement
of the extent to which mankind
is getting connected.
And of course,
we live in a rapidly,
rapidly urbanizing world.
Now, most of the
world's population
does live in cities already.
Part of this global
network civilization
part of this move from political
to functional geography is that
perhaps, not surprisingly
cities can be seen
as more important
in many ways than countries.
So, what is on this map is every
human being in the world.
You have the entire
world's population here
and you have the population
density as well.
And you have these ovals showing
you the kind of outlines
of where the largest, most
populous mega-city clusters are.
And then the large circles
tell you, what percentage
what share of the national
economy those cities represent.
So, what you're seeing here
is not only where
mankind is concentrated
but of course,
just how significant
those particular clusters
are where they're located.
And so,
30 or 40 of these
represent a growing share
of the world economy.
And by the year 2030,
most projections estimate
there will be about
50 mega-city archipelagos.
And these really represent
the preponderant share of the
world economic activity.
So, I've put, kind of all
of them up on one map here.
And again,
I ask the question
you're trying to understand
how the world works.
It's not a naive question
I wonder which map
tells you more.
This one or
the conventional ones?
Or maybe some mix of the two.
But certainly not one
that ignores this.
Because a map that ignores
this is not actually capturing
who we are, where we are
and what we do.
Part of this story is what
I call 'pop-up cities'.
Special Economic Zones.
Fifty years ago
we had almost
no Special Economic Zones
in the world today.
Geographies, industrial
parks that were set aside
and designated primarily
for the purpose
of attracting in
foreign investment
bringing in technology
training workers,
boosting exports
allowing countries and
their labor force
to rise up the value chain.
Today, we have 4,000
such Special Economic Zones
in the world today.
It is the most rapidly
expanding type of city.
So, this is a very significant
trend in the world today.
China has become an empire
of such mega cities.
Each of which has almost a
designated economic function
in the global supply chain.
And if you think about it,
it's fascinating.
It's very, very instructive
in the shift from political
to functional geography.
That the world's oldest
continuous civilization
with very diverse provincial
and linguistic histories
in many of its provinces,
would say
"That's all fine and good.
You can keep your dialects
and your culture and so on.
But, we need to organize
the country in a new way
so that each of these
mega-city clusters
has an internally
viable economy.
So, it has anywhere from
20 to 100 million people.
So that it has lots of
services and transactions
going on among people,
so it's not dependent
just on exporting one kind
of widget or product.
But, at the same time, each one
is very connected to each other
through high speed rail networks
and highways and so forth
and internationally
to the global economy.
And this process of
reorganizing the sort of
the management of a
country is something
that we're starting to
see around the world.
This is how I believe it should
happen in the United States.
What I'm basically
saying is that
the 50 United States
that we have
are very, very useful
when you're trying to win
an election.
When you're out
there campaigning
But, it tells you
absolutely nothing
about how to properly
govern America's geography
to be an economically
competitive superpower.
Right, what we need is for these
mega regions, if you will
that have certain
common internal
economic characteristics
like agriculture or industry
to be much more seamlessly
connected to each other
and to the outside world.
They need to be built around
urban economies at their core
and they need to be
connected to each other
through freight rail corridors
high speed rail networks
and so forth.
So, if you take this layering
of the natural
economic geographies
these big patches and the urban
clusters that are in white
that are gonna be
the economic hubs
and then the infrastructural
connectivity.
That's how you would turn
The United States of America
into United City-States
of America.
And that would be one, that
would be far more efficient
far more viable,
far more sensible
and certainly far
more competitive.
The optimistic note
that I want to end on
and that I end the book on
is this idea that
we are actually returning
to a fairly ancient model.
We are a coastal urban
network civilization.
Right, a world in which
people are more interested
in trade and commerce with
each other than conquest.
And this is what I call
the Pax Urbanica,
a peace among cities
in which, if we think about
the way cities view the world
versus the way
countries view the world.
Cities are interested in
trade and connectivity
whereas, we think of
countries being interested
in territorial aggrandizement.
And so, the more we
move into a world
in which that mentality of
inter-urban connectivity
in sharing lessons with each
other, trading with each other
positive sum relations
the more peaceful ultimately,
the entire world system can be.
But, the punch line
really is that
if you want to have this world,
you actually have to build it.
And it starts with,
what we're doing today
and what we could
do a lot more of.
Which is investing, first and
foremost in connectivity.
Connectivity for countries,
connectivity for cities
and connectivity for people.
And with that, I'll stop.
Thank you so very much.
-( audience applause )
-Thank you.